good morning that's the sick me I get to
please when we join from the defense my
dream business intelligence committee
want me to say
there's a running backwards trying to do
you bump into a lamppost any moment you
better be careful are you going to be
join you're very childish
and here we go again how many
photographs you can actually use that's
great I'll help you spread you with
activity you really must learn better to
walk backwards you know it's it requires
a skill you should have learnt about her
Grif I know it's great fun
and feel next one don't go to the road
you might hurt yourself
yeah now you're on private property now
you break it off you'll be in trouble
well done